hello everybody this is matt walker
production manager on resident evil
revelations 2 with capcom global R&D i'm
here today with our producer on the
title mich state Okabe what Kyra sound
how you doing today alright good deal
and now we're going to show you raid
mode and resident evil revelations 2 as
you can see here we've already started
out this is looks probably completely
different from what you're used to if
you've played raid mode and revelations
one in Revelations one you'd access raid
mode you'd start out from some menus and
then you'd start playing and here we
decided that we really wanted to kind of
grade up revelations tues raid mode from
what we've had in Revelations once so we
wanted to give it its own thing we want
to give its own kind of setting here and
really make players feel like they're a
little more immersed in the experience
so here we go okay besides already
jumped into the character select menu
here we have all kinds of different
characters that you're going to be able
to select from and you'll notice here as
what cabochons is kind of looking at the
different characters that right off the
bat you have a couple different
characters you can select and you can
unlock new ones as well and there's
going to be a difference between
characters right off the bat in that
they're going to start with kind of
different stuff so Barry here he's got
three weapons slots that he's already
got open from the beginning but only one
active skill slot open but then Claire
she has two weapon slots that are open
and two active skill slots and then as
they progress here you'll see you'll
notice we have padlocks here that
indicate what level you're gonna have to
level that character up to to access
that next thing so here we go Oh
cabochon is selected Barry and he's
going to select those weapons for the
missions that he's about to play and
then we also have the skill menu as well
and so the you can select different
skills as you play through the mode here
so far Barry's only the only active
skill these got unlocked is the firebomb
and so we start off in what we call the
vestibule here in raid mode
this is kind of like the home base for
players Oh Cabo San just selected his
character now we went over the parts
bench and you can upgrade your weapons
here if you're going to get various
parts throughout the game either by
finding records in the missions which
will show you guys in a bit or by buying
from the in-game store and you can take
these parts and you can equip them to
your weapons and that's going to give
your weapons all kinds of different
functionality you know anything from
making your weapons stronger too for
instance giving it I samo so that it's
going to have a nice attribute so you
can take out you know fire enemies more
easily so copper sounds going to go
ahead and start from mission 3 here the
first engine isn't particularly too hard
you know it's kind of available for
people to get their feet wet can't
understand and figure out what exactly
raid mode is all about so start off in
the mission 3 it's not going to be too
hard for him hopefully no captions can
be playing raid mode single player right
now but if you feel like it's getting a
little tough for you and you want to
bring in a friend you can always play
right off the bat you can be able to
play splitscreen local multiplayer with
somebody as long as it got two
patrollers there you just have a friend
come in and help you out and then we're
going to have online available later on
in a patch and the title update that we
put out later so all the not necessarily
all of the enemies and raid mode are
going to be enemies specifically from a
campaign of Revelations too but at least
as you start out here yep these these
are enemies that people should be
familiar with we have the afflicted to
these guys that then cabochons or
shooting right is shooting right now
these guys are the kind of first enemies
you come up against an eclair and Moira
King and then you have these other guys
that look a little more little tougher
little looks like they've had a little
more we're here they're called the
rotten and they're the first enemy that
you come up again
Varian Natalia's camp but we are going
to have peach be featuring some other
enemies that aren't necessarily
exclusive to revelations 2 throughout
raid mode as well we want to wedge say
who and what you're going to be fighting
against yet that's something that we
look forward to having people play and
figure out and find out as they get a
chance to experience the game themselves